[Music]
you know no you didn't news oh don't you
they submitted by feels Batman here's a
bad man feels Batman feels Batman Batman
a lawyer went on a racist tirade about
the Asians that took over Orange County
is it the same guy the same Laura that's
been yelling at everyone else no okay
yes yes our fans gifts only goes this
isn't this lady like 15 years too late
we've been taking over Orange concrete
long long long long maybe she was in a
coma
Oh a dentist's office I like a bomb she
took him over to we took everything over
there's not a dentist office that
without an Asian name on it dentist nail
salon yup liquor store more even taking
over notaries oh yeah true we just got
some [ __ ] they're just like a clean-cut
white dentist you know that's gone on
that I never had that my dentist was
always Filipino really oh yeah that's
true all of my ten tests have always
been Asian mine were always like a white
guy looked like he may be played
baseball and you can't want to break
your hand on his face kind of baby where
that [ __ ] thing yeah yeah they had
that whole thing yeah what thing the
[ __ ] thing on the stereotypical like
medal for the medal yeah oh isn't that
hella old don't they just have like a
light all right so this woman she went
viral for her post her name is Christina
this is what she looks like
that [ __ ] is heavily edited girl yeah I
love the hunters ways our lawyer yeah oh
that's the same [ __ ] you do to your and
nothing no way you talk about it no idea
what the [ __ ] you're talking about what
I'm talking about
you wanna plug my Instagram you can go
ahead and do that yeah pull it up I
don't know what I'm talkin about
follow Steve green at VAR tkw am hey
wait a minute that's not the link
believes oh well nobody gets it wrong
she claims that she's the most well
known and most respected and most
requested law tutor in the nation that's
what she says about herself law tutor
says who was hurt
yeah so she posted
I'll read it this and this okay so it's
that or would you like to read it be the
agents that took over Orange County on
all caps my friend said that there's
something coming out called crazy rich
occasions it reminds me of all the
Asians who flooded into Orange County
and then took over our mall South Coast
Plaza in fact they came up with a
shopping word called snotty it stands
for posh and snobby you can see them
around Fendi do your Gucci and Louis
Vuitton they have a zoned in personality
where the act as if no one exists and
they just run straight in front of you
to grab the next purse they also drive
this way near South Coast Plaza they
will drive in there miss a DS in a
carpool lane cut across five lanes to
get over to the mall as if your car
that's why we have the term driving like
an Asian but now they're trying to get
tutoring from me for Law School
they keep telling me they're attending
UC RA I need to translate that now I had
to deduce what that they're going into
UCLA if you want to you see a like I did
you probably went to school a lot of
rice Rockets Asians what did that school
is if they were smart and could get in
no she said Asian slaw at that school if
they were smarting to get in my bed they
went there to become doctors they were
raised by Tiger moms who told them to
become doctor schools called University
of Chinese immigrants that's just like
80% Chinese and then if they were not
smart enough to become a doctor to marry
doctor if they didn't marry a doctor
then they were encouraged to marry a
lawyer yes my sucker Caucasian male
lawyer friends who married Asian women
were completely poached I'm one of those
suckers
we're completely put four dollars and
earning potential at UCI they brought
their obnoxiously lowered and really
loud speedster cars that can't handle
the speed bumps in the parking structure
she'll drive 1 mile an hour to get over
them Jesus Christ well so you need to
drive 1 hour
one hour behind I'm one mile an hour
behind this so far it's a hundred
percent of fact done if you thought you
can get away from them
for a hot second and go on vacation to
Yosemite think again because they're
there too if they came in huge buses and
stood in front of each waterfall to give
a peace sign in there and there's
selfies this [ __ ] is fed up though from
one annoying thing to another welcome
the Asians dam that's tight
she's mainly talking about mainland
Chinese Fox yeah and and I think just
they're annoying a lot of people like
like they don't because they [ __ ] run
in front of people and then I see other
mainland Chinese people that are more
Americanized even they're judging those
guys yeah they're just looking at them
like I can't believe these Chinese
people all right you're Chinese to what
the hell they get offended if you even
like cross them like oh you're from the
same place [ __ ] no we're not there's
been [ __ ] somewhere else they're like
no but we are but they're not we're not
like those mainlanders and it's like I
think it's getting all [ __ ] up cuz
they think we're just one group yeah I
can't even get mad at her because she's
so specific and accurate that I know
she's actually been dealing with this
[ __ ] and it's not her stereotyping or
anything it's all true over the things
she groups all the Asians together and I
feel like Japanese people don't do
[ __ ] half of this [ __ ] so I'm just
like what are you talking about but it's
bad driving really an Asian thing yes
cuz I get caught by every [ __ ] I
swear to God
keep telling me that for some reason
agents have like not so good depth
perception that's what it was so bad I
don't know there's a lot of really good
baseball players are Asian and there's a
lot of Asian race car drivers so to him
and you just meet groups and all you
guys I think that's that's true through
because you told me he was like he's
like you know what I found out I found
out Asians have very small wrists no it
was this bone and he showed me his
wrists I'm like your wrists are small
bro like that every in OKC has dainty
wrists so I don't know I think he's
all conclusion I got sprained when she
fell on it does he think he's like the
average common Asian body type and and
like he's not cuz he's hung like a
[ __ ] horse huge [ __ ] [ __ ] dude no
that's that's that's average age
honestly I think he gets it I mean so
like his his dad really likes to
generalize a lot yeah so he like his dad
will say like yeah Asians like we which
is a Cantonese thing they love maybe
it's the Cantonese that's some low as IQ
[ __ ] dude seriously like think about it
there's billions of [ __ ] people there
all the way from South South Asia all
the way to Japan like you're you you
can't group them up into one group and
say that it's true all across the
brightness just the northern Chinese are
completely different specimens anyone
else like this but it's not just like
Chinese people he likes to generalize a
lot like for everything like yeah that's
what I mean that's that's kind of stupid
like that's stupid thinking you don't
mean but that's that's it is going
that's older generation agent thinking
like because if you think about it they
don't have the the same like they don't
they don't they're not used to googling
[ __ ] immediately like they here they're
so used to it a fasting for them yeah
everyone thinks or they get it from the
newspaper or like they get it from what
their friend said or they make their own
observations in this way you're
criticizing Casey's dead for saying that
most Asians do certain things finally
yes it's funny it's hard breaking
through no no it's funny because it
exists oh it's funny to point out the
stereotype just like half of this [ __ ]
this girl's saying I can't get mad at
because it exists and it's like oh yeah
it's a Asian thing they do this right
but but really if you want to like
narrow down and be specific it's like a
mainland Chinese thing but people don't
not understand that now people don't
understand it but I'm also I get where
they're coming from because there's so
much of this that it's like yeah there's
probably like what was that like
minority black group like Creole or
whatever right like yeah there's Creole
yeah there's whatever but there's just
so much of this type of Asian behavior
that when people say Asians do mainland
Chinese it's generally
I just generally accept it I [ __ ]
hate it because it's a new thing like
you don't see any Hong Kong Korea and
Japanese you don't see anybody like
[ __ ] cutting people and lie be rude
like it's not it's not even close to
that that's a new thing and it's it's
like a new bad stereotype yeah Halloween
Horror Nights in Burbank or not Burbank
Universal Universal dude [ __ ]
everybody cuts in line it's everybody
and I mean like it's like like you could
say Oh West LA people drive horribly
that's a West la thing right like all
those and then they're all white but
like they're all like in a rush because
their time is just so much more
important than ever okay what is it what
do you know why people kept sending it
in so she posted after that that whole
thing went viral she took it down up to
15 minutes by the way she ended up
posting something else she said so I
posted something funny about crazy rich
Asians apparently it was so provocative
that it was considered abuse I had no
idea that talking about stereotypes
would be so provocative somehow my post
goes down but this one manages to stay
up with ten million views ah yes the
great value it and having Facebook and
all of your dumb so-called friends
floating around you by the way I do not
hate Asians I really love them and I
find differences to be funny and
interesting she posted JK films [ __ ]
Asian mom say funny obviously there's a
difference between us creating that and
her [ __ ] post it's totally different
what's the difference for you she
should've acted it out yeah and I mean
also I think ours come from a place of
love like there's no love in what she
was writing it's all frustration and
hate that's what I think people [ __ ] up
on I don't know that the genesis of the
thing is what makes it provocative it's
like I could laugh at other groups being
frustrated at them yeah I could be like
oh I saw this [ __ ] in mainland Chinese
do take a piss and take a dump on the
floor but it's not coming from a place
of love it's coming from a place of
frustration like why do you do that you
know like it's it's not it's making me
look bad so in her case I
the intent was like its out of
frustration I don't get it it's my maybe
my white culture is getting like flooded
with something else and now I have to
accept and deal with this new [ __ ] that
I don't want to deal with that's what it
sounds like to me versus us it's like
hey these are some funny things and
funny quirks that we have that you know
we're communicating so or how you were
raised or things that you've enjoyed
that's what's fun about like stand up
right like pointing out stereotypes from
the place of like fun and funny Ness and
making fun of and yeah like it's not
like it's not like a Hitler on the dice
like talking on the dais like talking to
a bunch of people and being like yo [ __ ]
all these fools oh yeah they're like
yeah it's like pointing out things and
stereotypes could be really fun and
funny and we all like enjoyed them but
it's yeah coming from the mean place is
what makes it all a bummer right it's
like inclusive versus exclusive yeah
we're like yeah yeah basically cuz it's
like this is probably funny to everybody
that's not Asian I mean still funny to
me too but you know but it's definitely
you guys you a lot of your guys you
mister too but I could take it yeah even
if if it comes from a place of
frustration and hey I could still take
it because it's I get it you know I mean
so far when you were just saying that
you thought that this was funny you were
you offended by this at all cuz it
sounds like you just Excel I wasn't no I
wasn't offended by it and I thought it
was really funny of how accurate it was
I think if she had a comedian's mind
she's like one step away from having a
really dope set that people would be
like when the first Russell Peters came
out and people were like loved him for
his how accurate his Chinese accent was
and how how stingy they are like I think
she's like one step away but because I
have a comedian's mind when she's saying
these things it's already converting him
I'm like that's not true that's so true
that's not true that's oh I wanted to
know what what are your guys's feelings
they're like what your thoughts about
the fact that you used your video to
justify what she was saying I mean I
basically said it earlier where it's I
see it as two different things where she
created content based off of her
frustration toward Asians versus us
creating content
show the the little funny quirks that we
have it's I think it's two different
things it's not really like hey we're
making fun of stereotypes but it all
depends on the intent behind it so like
I think a good comedian comes from a
place of let's laugh together and not
really let's just laugh at this for the
sake of laughing at if you even look at
the comments a lot of people are like oh
my god my mom does that to you or oh
yeah group and people feel it people
feel the difference okay cause they like
even her complaints it just sounds
really petty so even her complaints it
made me laugh because it's not like oh
man this group of people come into my
neighborhood and Brod me and like kill
us or steal our [ __ ] it's like these
guys come in with their Mercedes
becoming doctors it's like [ __ ] that
like it doesn't bother anyone but you so
it's just even her complaints to me are
really really petty it's like people
with their nice clothes it does it
himself it does even sound like an
insult the way that she's complaining so
you you weren't this is not offensive
you just kind of funny no not to me oh
yeah
[Music]